[Music]
I am trapped down here all the exits are
closed and it's after me I I don't know
if anyone will ever see this but you
need to know
that you need to
know
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that reminds you to never
trespass on private property cuz you
might just get stuck in an analog horror
series ladies and gentlemen Kane pixels
has done it again taking a break from
working on his back rooms feature film
to give us a brand new series known as
the oldest View and while the series
certainly draws a lot of ideas and
inspiration from Kane's back rooms
videos something that the series itself
calls out this is literally like the uh
the back rooms uh from Tik Tok it is
still very much its own thing in case
you've missed this one the oldest view
is a more cinematic piece than Kane's
previous back rooms videos combining his
trademark found footage Style with a
couple of scenes that are more
traditionally shot in the series we find
ourselves behind the camera of a college
YouTube vlogger named Wyatt and what
starts off as a normal hiking Vlog Wyatt
takes us to this weird hole that he
found at the base of a large tree
revealing a stair case that descends
straight down into the Earth and out of
sight and as any good YouTuber would
Wyatt decides to enter this obviously
dangerous mysterious stairwell all in
pursuit of that sweet sweet content at
the bottom almost a mile underground he
finds something completely unexpected an
abandoned a shopping mall but
unfortunately for Wyatt though the
mall's devoid of human life he isn't
alone slowly he's stalked by a
mysterious monster a large papier-mâché
statue on Wheels pulled Straight Out of
The Uncanny Valley a statue who seems to
hate the fact that his home has been
Disturbed let me tell you I wasn't sure
that Kane was going to be able to
recapture the mysterious and hor horic
lightning in a bottle that he found with
the back rooms but it's been a while
since a piece of media like this has
kept me at the edge of my seat and of
course just like with the back rooms Kan
has packed this thing to the gills with
tons of hidden lore and blink and you'll
miss it references in other words it was
practically begging for an episode the
questions here are just too intriguing
not to dive into what is the oldest view
really about what's with this rolling
giant thing and why is it stalk in an
abandoned Mall heck what even is the
deal with that mall and why is it a mile
underground well when you actually stop
and do the research underneath the
layers of analog horror is a touching
story about longing for the past and how
to embrace Nostalgia without getting
consumed by it the craziest part all of
it is told through the lens of real
people real places and Real History yeah
the monster here it really exists so
grab your camera phones and let's go to
them all loyal theorists it's time we
head down the stairs into the oldest
view so I feel like the best place to
start is with a quick recap of the
events that we see in the series itself
the first episode is a bit of a strange
one given Kane's previous releases it's
a lot more atmospheric and traditionally
cinematic than his previous work with
the back rooms we open in a forest here
we see a man walking around picking
flowers and scribbling in a small
notebook but what's interesting is that
while the Forest around him is bustling
with life full of the green color that
you'd expect to find in the woods the
man himself is black and white literally
monochromatic that said we don't stick
around with this guy long quickly
cutting to scenes of someone's
terrifying arts and crafts project
eventually creating an ominous mask
wonder if that one's going to come up
again spoiler alert it does second and
third episodes take on a style a lot
closer to what we've been used to
putting us in the shoes of Wyatt the
YouTube vlogger that we mentioned at the
top of the episode what's up guys Wyatt
here Wyatt takes his viewers down the
mysterious stairwell that he found in
the middle of nowhere descending Down
and Out of Sight before eventually
finding himself in that abandoned mall
after exploring around for a bit Wyatt
finds that all the stores are closed and
that the exits of the mall just lead out
to rock walls but while it seems Wyatt
is alone at first he eventually runs
into this nightmare fuel this isn't just
some weird Modern Art p this creature
known as the rolling giant starts to
follow Wyatt around the mall an animate
object somehow coming to life and
stalking him I'm leaving trying to leave
deciding that the views just aren't
going to be worth it Wyatt heads back to
the stairs where he entered only to find
that he's been caved in he's trapped in
here with this murderous paper mâché
monster and only a few options while
running from the creature Wyatt finds
himself in the mall's back room hallways
eventually leading to an office space
that has a map of the mall and
directions to another exit but as Wyatt
leaves the office back rooms and heads
back into the main part of the mall it's
changed it's become overgrown by plants
and Wildlife undeterred whyatt begins
climbing for the exit that he found on
the map unfortunately the rafters
collapse and Wyatt Falls only for the
episode to once again shift into a more
cinematic atmospheric scene similar to
those of the first episode here we see
Wyatt's corpse and broken phone laying
in the dirt of the same forest from the
beginning as the giant looks on hidden
in the trees so huh what the heck's
going on with this thing well the way I
see it there are three main mysteries in
the series so far number one what's up
with the M number two what is this
monster supposed to be and number three
what's it all trying to tell us so let's
just do our best to break down what we
can starting with what's going on in the
mall almost immediately after
discovering it Wyatt finds a sign
designating this as Valley View Center
there are also a bunch of references to
the city of Dallas Texas I keep seeing
Dallas show up I thought this was a
really strange and specific detail so we
did a bit of digging we found that the
Valley View Center is actually a very
real place that actually existed in
Dallas Texas but we should also note
that the series clearly doesn't take
place in Dallas and likely not in Texas
at all first off the Flora and Landscape
in the outdoor area that we see towards
the beginning of Wyatt Vlogs looks a lot
more like what you'd expect to find in
central California this absolutely makes
sense when you consider that Kane is
from that part of California but it's
not just a production decision as
Wyatt's exploring them all he himself
seems to think it's weird that he keeps
seeing signs for Dallas everywhere I
keep seeing Dallas show up but I'm not
sure if it's talking about the City but
I've seen like two Texas shops and it's
on a lot of signs so right off the bat
that's pretty darn weird right what's
this mall from Dallas Texas doing in
California and maybe more importantly
why is it underground well it's
important to note that the Valley View
Center doesn't actually exist anymore
just like most other malls in the US the
Valley View Center was hit hard by the
2000s thanks in large part to online
shopping and companies like Amazon
taking much of their business by 2012
the mall was bought out by an investment
group called Beck Ventures who didn't
plan to save the dying mall but instead
demolish it and rebuild the land into a
completely different shopping district
known as Dallas Midtown in fact you can
see part of Beck's plan to do this
inside of the oldest view as Wyatt's
exploring the office space you can spot
several artistic renderings and
publicity images displayed on one of the
walls that he walks by the very same
ones that you can find in real life if
you go to the actual website for the
Dallas Midtown project see side by side
there they are one and the same why is
that a big deal well it's at this point
that we should stop and acknowledge that
because this building was entirely
demolished earlier this year here it
means that everything we see inside the
oldest view here is 100% CGI everything
from the giant AMC to the name8
vegetables that start with b sign all
painstakingly recreated digitally and if
the comments from Dallas locals are any
indication he did a bang up job of
bringing their memories to life I don't
just bring that up to show how
impressive Kane's work here is he chose
this specific mall and these specific
assets on the walls for reasons and it
all comes down to the rolling giant that
stalks Wyatt throughout the video why
well this leads us to mystery number two
what's the deal with the monster follow
me here like most cities do Dallas is no
stranger to gassen up their local
celebrities that either came from the
city or help put the city on the map but
while most other cities would just leave
it at building statues or naming
buildings after that famous person
Dallas does something a little bit
different with their metaphorical Giants
they turned them into literal Giants see
in 2012 a group of local artists in
Dallas organized something they called
the parade of giants where many famous
dysonian from the city's past would be
lovingly recreated as large statue es
statues that would then get rolled
through the streets you see where I'm
going with this one right at the same
time as the pre to Giants before the
Valley View Center was sold and
demolished many of its storefronts were
rented to local artists to Showcase
their work in a push known as The
Gallery at Midtown this has become a
Haven for local Dallas artists while
this mall is undergoing a transition
something we see referenced not only on
the first sign that Wyatt comes across
but also all across the mall one of
these artists was Kevin oon we can
actually see his Studio among others as
whyatt strolls across the mall and the
giant that he created for the parade yep
it is one and the same with the giant
that we see stalking Wyatt throughout
the mall a statue who was the literal
poster child for the parade of giants so
if these statues are meant to be real
people important to Dallas history who
is this giant bason well according to
the description for the third episode
the creature is credited to oon and
named the Julian Riverson Giants if you
didn't know and I mean why would you
know this Julian Riverson was a bot
someone who studies plants born in
France in 1837 now those factoids right
there should already be connecting some
dots for you firstly the giant itself
seems to be made of plants notice those
massive plant-like hands secondly the
stairwell down to this creepy abandoned
Mall it was found at the base of a large
tree again showing a connection with
plants and finally our point of view
character Wyatt what's he studying in
college again oh yeah botney I was able
to get a couple of trail cameras from my
old botney Professor clearly there's
meant to be a connection here and
perhaps this is a clue as to why the
mall is so far underground beneath a
tree it is the roots to our story anyway
in 1856 Julian revon and his father
moved to the US heading for a settlement
called luno which is now Dallas Texas
unfortunately travel took ages back in
the 1800s and by the time they
eventually got there luno had basically
collapsed instead of just turning around
though and heading back to France rever
sha stuck around and joined the nearby
community of Dallas back when it was
only a few hundred farmers and from
there he was pretty instrumental in the
development of Dallas into the
Metropolis that it is today becoming
something of a local celebrity while
expanding his plant Collections and
teaching others about botney at Baylor
University College revon Park in the
city was even named after julon after he
died reveron is clearly an important
person to the story not only is this
creature based on a real sculpture of
the guy but it isn't the only time that
he shows up during the third episode
when Wyatt returns to the store that he
found the Giant in there's a portrait of
a man in one of the storefronts labeled
Julian riversa in front of it is a
single twig with leaves on it a nod to
the Giant and rev shon's career as a
botanist finally reveron is also our
connection to the mysterious man in the
first episode of the oldest view
remember that guy the dude stuck in
black and white while the rest of the
forest is green well on IMDb The
Character is credited as Julian rers
Shaw he's the dude who's out here
existing in nature picking flowers
scribbling in his notebook doing his
General bot nesty things which brings us
then to mystery number three why what
what does any of this even mean this
series clearly has a lot of very
specific very Regional references to
real world people events and history
this stuff was not put here on accident
this isn't meant to be a bunch of Easter
eggs or random decisions this all means
something and I think we can decipher it
starting here in the back rooms of the
mall well in the office Wyatt finds
himself a piece of paper that describes
fire safety protocols for the Valley
View Center it is very detailed it even
refers to several other documents with
numbers on them each with a specific
purpose but if you break down the
numbers they all have hidden meanings
they're all dates that describe very
specific periods of time document 18551
1857 can be broken down into the years
1855 and 1857 the exact date range that
the L reunion settlement outside of
Dallas existed remember this was the
place that rev sha was leaving France
for before the community collapsed and
rev sha was forced to move to Dallas the
next document 1973 2023 refers to the
dates 1973 to 2023 if you dig into the
history of the Valley View Center Mall
you'll find that it was first built in
1973 and that The Last Remnant of it was
demolished earlier this year in 2023 and
finally the third document references
1837 and 1905 the years Reva was born
and died but we can actually take things
even deeper by looking at the
instructions attached to each of these
numbers see these aren't just Easter
eggs they're Clues to tell us what the
series is trying to say at least
thematically document 18551 1857 the one
referencing launo refers to emergency
assembly points places to safely Gather
in the event of a fire described as a
safe distance from the building if it
were ever to have structural issues from
damage if this is is meant to be where
you go in the case of an emergency it
cannot be a coincidence that the numbers
are pointing to a town that ultimately
didn't survive it's pretty ironic one
that's even more interesting though is
document 18371 1905 the one pointing to
rever Sha's life this one is talking
about what people should do if the exit
routes become inaccessible in other
words this document seems to be
thematically telling us the way out of
this situation the way to solve Wyatt's
problem and escape from this danger is
going to be looking at rever sha himself
his life his decisions what was
important to him and what the giant
represents throughout the series what do
I mean by that well think about what we
actually see the reveron giant doing
throughout the videos he aggressively
follows Wyatt and Spooks him but he
doesn't kill Wyatt in fact the only real
indication that we have of what the
Giant's after as the giant Corners him
Wyatt asks what do you want and the
giant shows him something strange the
lights flicker and suddenly there's a
pair of dead horses and dead men on the
floor these are clearly things that
Riverson the real one would have
witnessed at some point during his life
these men dressed in old CL clothes and
the horses and whatnot classic cowboy
stuff all a flash from rev Sha's past
and this sense of a flashback isn't just
present here in the first episode of the
series as rev sha is picking flowers and
the Giants being made we can hear a song
titled when the swallows Homeward fly
and if you listen to the lyrics they
very much lean into these same feelings
of sadness and Nostalgia quote when the
summer days are gone when the Roses fade
and die and no more has heard the song
Parting oh parting is grief and pain
this is a song about nostalgia because
this is a series about Nostalgia both
the good and the bad ways that you can
hold on to it honestly this song this is
what made everything click for me as I
was really sitting down to crack the
series the decision to tell this story
with reverol and these themes in a mall
of all places really bothered me like
sure I guess the sculpture is from here
but why dive into this particular story
with this man in this place and then it
hit me just before Wyatt exits the back
rooms and finds them all overtaken by
plants you can see this poster for just
the briefest of moments it reads do you
accept this impermanence that right
there not exactly a motivational phrase
you'd expect to find in a typical
workplace especially one that has been
so painstakingly recreated by cane no
this poster was put here to make a point
and uh you know what's truly impermanent
in this series the mall it's gone it is
a vacant lot in Dallas Texas now
evidence of its impermanence for all to
see that is what the oldest view is
about it's a Nostalgia trip for anyone
from the area you don't have to take my
word for it out of the nearly 177,000
comments left on the third episode at
the time that I'm writing this Kane
chose to like just four of them each one
mentioning the strange sense of
nostalgia that they got from seeing the
small that they remember but will never
see again in real life even if you
aren't from Dallas if you're a certain
age range you're probably still going to
be feeling a similar sense of nostalgia
sure almost everyone who's watched or
will ever watch the oldest view will
have never Ste foot into the Valley View
Center but malls were very much a
ubiquitous part of American culture for
decades but as more and more of life has
shifted online it is harder and harder
for malls to stay in business many have
closed their doors forever with
estimates saying that only 700 are still
open in the US in 2022 Nostalgia is a
powerful emotion it's bittersweet it
also brings a certain type of comfort
scientists have vied Nostalgia to
alleviate depression and homesickness in
soldiers and I think that is the feeling
that the oldest view is trying to
capture here despite the spoopy scary
imagery look back at those comments that
people from Dallas left about seeing
Valley View in the video none of them
were sad they were grateful they were
happy to reminisce about this thing that
was a part of their lives and is now
forever gone they were able to bask in
that impermanence one final time it was
important to them to honor that memory
and not to just milk it for clout and
then run away from it afraid like Wyatt
which is why he eventually had to die
impermanence is the way of nature it's
the way of life all things eventually
come to an end and you either Embrace
that or else you're fighting a losing
battle that's something a bnst like
revon would know all too well but hey
that's just a theory a film Theory and
[Music]
cut
sh